Loading these TILEDmaps is actually a pretty complex process, so we're going to
walk through it piece by piece. First, to parse the JSON, you'll notice that
we've actually modified our load function call to call parseMapJSON with the
data we get from our xhr request. Now the data we've received from the internet
is actually a JSON blob. The first thing we need to do is actually call
JSON.parse, passing the JSON blob, to actually give us an object in Javascript.
Next, what we'd like to do is to actually cache some of the values of this new
JSON object inside of the map class itself, so, we don't have to keep walking
through and querying that data object later on. The parameters we care about
keeping track of right now are the total number of tiles crossing down in the
atlas. The size of each of those tiles in pixels, and then the size of the
entire map in pixels. Now, once you've retrieved that data from our JSON object,
go ahead and set the fullyLoaded attribute to true.